yellowtail amberjack sashimi grilled and
steamed langoustine a desserts made of
pistachio nuts raspberries and limes
many gourmets can spot a dish made by
christian bow on site the new chef of
the year is one of the first in Germany
to combine Japanese influences with
classic French oak cuisine we use a lot
of fish often preparing it the way the
Japanese do that means we use a lot of
raw fish and a lot of very briefly
poached fish rarely with cream sauces or
things like that
in our dishes the focus is always on the
basic ingredient whose inherent flavor
we have to accentuate and all-around
it's an array of fantastic side dishes
not far from the border with Luxembourg
and France gourmets enter a renaissance
castle to be pampered by the three-star
chef since 1998 bow and his 20 person
team have worked to realize his vision
of fine dining
the products they use come from all over
the world and are always of the finest
quality like this yellowtail amberjack
straight from the Tokyo fish market
yellowtail amberjack is also available
in a compact already filleted from fish
farmers in New Zealand and Australia
their product has the same name
yellowtail amberjack but it's quite
different for a long time bow restricted
himself to classic French cuisine but
after he was awarded his third Michelin
star in 2005 he realized he wanted to do
something else
trips to Asia and especially to Japan
expanded his culinary horizon he began
combining the best of both worlds
hardly any butter cream or meat instead
of vegetable oils exotic fruits and fish
he developed a style of his own and it
was soon popular all over Germany Java
need democracy and I never aim to
faithfully cook someone else's recipe it
was important to me to combine the style
of cuisine that I had already been
practicing with new things and to build
a bridge between France and Japan
the ambience in the restaurant is
minimalist new tablecloths and the
waiters don't wear ties the background
music is in classical but electronic
everything is focused on enjoying the
food every detail is importance even
including the right plate for each dish
we have a credo here my wife and I and
the company we want to make people happy
with our work we're service providers at
the very top level and that's how we see
ourselves
we're not obsequious we don't bow and
scrape or crawl on the floor we want to
meet our guests as equals and provide
them with a service on the very highest
loving being named chef of the year
means Christian bow has achieved just
about everything he can in his
profession but he's still passionate
about his work and so gourmets from all
over the world can continue to take
pleasure in his exciting culinary
combinations
you